So, I grew up in a place
called McLean, Virginia,
right outside of D.C.
But I, like, split
my childhood, basically.
So we'll start with where
I first grew up,
so I'm really excited
to show you guys this.
- So this is my hometown.
- Wow, that's cool.
We were the only
black family on the block.
I was the only black kid
in my grade.
One of three
black families in my school.
And if we look, folks are in
the 99th percentile
who grew up here when
it comes to average income.
Less than 1%
are incarcerated.
We can look at teenage
birth rate-- less than 1%.
Around high school,
my folks got divorced
and we moved into the city.
It's the exact opposite.
It wasn't till I got to D.C.
that I actually had a benchmark
for understanding everyone
didn't grow up the way I did.
And it took, you know,
my parents getting divorced
and us moving to the city
for me to actually
understand how fortunate
I really was.
Zip code influences so much
that we have got to make sure
that those
neighborhood conditions
aren't setting people up
for failure.
We are keeping people
of reasonable means
out of neighborhoods.
While I was doing some research,
I came across this,
which is the Opportunity Atlas.
And it's a map that shows you
the average life outcomes
for people who grew up
in a given census tract.
It's just crazy to think
that I may have only
become as successful as I am
because I spent the majority
of my childhood here
instead of in D.C.
But why don't we take a look
at where you guys grew up?
Dun, dun, dun.
( theme music playing )
- Lee: So, you're,
like in the Bay area.
- Christophe: Oh, yeah.
- I must have grew up in
Cupertino, California.
- Lee: Okay.
Christophe: Majority Asian.
Definitely fairly wealthy.
- A lot of, like, tech,
Silicon Valley employees.
- Lee: Right.
All right. So I'm gonna put in
my zip code where I grew up.
So I just took you guys
to Brooklyn, New York,
Crown Heights,
and immediately traveling here,
it's just completely red.
Yeah, so, $30k, that makes
a lot of sense to me.
But is also just--
this shows how segregated
Brooklyn is
and was at the time.
Fabiola: Yeah. So right here
at Grand Army Plaza,
it just looks so different
from the blocks
where I grew up in Brooklyn.
And so that was
out Saturday activity.
Let's go to the library.
Let's go to the park.
And that was kind of escaping
a lot of the segregation
in Crown Heights
to go to this area where
the amenities were better.
Did you notice those
neighborhoods being cleaner?
Absolutely. And I think
the biggest thing was trees.
- Right.
- Just like how many trees
do you have on your block?
I think it does
something to your psyche
where it's like,
oh, I feel like
I can breathe better.
I feel like someone cared
enough to beautify this area.
Well, guys, thank you
for taking the time out
to come look at this with me
- and showing me
where you grew up.
- This is so cool.
I want to talk
to this professor at NYU
to see if I can get some
information and some insight
into how we actually got here.
Jacob:
So I think the overarching
important message to take away
is that segregation
was intentionally designed.
- There are a number of--
- Designed by who?
By a wide range of policy makers
on the local level
all the way up
to the federal level.
When did we start
to see the government
actually leading
a lot of these programs
when it came to segregation?
So the federal government
instituted these
massive housing programs
during the New Deal
to save a housing market
that was in severe distress.
Their first policy
was called the Home Owner's
Loan Corporation,
or H.O.L.C. or "hulk."
Part of H.O.L.C.
was sending appraisers,
real estate appraisers
to hundreds of cities
across the country.
And these appraisers
would grade neighborhoods
in these cities,
and this is where the term
redlining comes from.
Lee:
In your lease it would say,
"You cannot resell this house
to a black family."
- Jacob: Yeah.
- So, let me explain.
As these appraisers surveyed
cities across the United States,
they created maps that
they distributed to banks.
And the banks used these maps
to decide how risky
it would be to provide loans
or mortgage assistance
to different neighborhoods
around the country,
and each of these maps
was assigned a color.
So green indicated this
was the most desirable area,
and the map we're looking
at right now is an area
in the northern suburbs
of Chicago.
And along with these maps,
we were given documents
that described
the neighborhood
that was being surveyed.
If we take a look at the top,
we can see the class
and occupation.
We can also see the number
of black families in this area,
and the preferred nomenclature
of the 1930s was Negro.
There were zero.
Moving on to
the next classification
were blue neighborhoods.
And blue neighborhoods
were considered
to still be desirable.
So as we take a look
at the description
of this blue area in Chicago,
the percentage of foreign
families is still zero.
The percentage
of Negro families, still none.
And as we come down
to the description, we see
the area is well laid out
and the improvements
are attractive,
but the proximity
of Negro families
on Spruce Street
at the southern edge
precludes the district
from a better rating
and is retarding
its development.
The proximity
of Negro families.
That's so crazy.
So as you can see,
these maps didn't ignore race.
In fact, they were
heavily dependent on it.
Race played a key factor
in determining the value
of these neighborhoods
and their ratings to the banks.
The yellow neighborhoods were
listed as definitely declining.
This one had
50% foreign families,
those foreign families
being Polish and German.
Race wasn't the only
determining factor
in whether or not these
neighborhoods had value.
Immigrant families heavily
impacted whether or not
it got a favorable evaluation.
And as we move on
to the last designation
of these neighborhoods,
we come to red neighborhoods.
And this is actually where
we get the term redlining from.
These neighborhoods
were defined as hazardous.
And when we look at
the description of the area,
the number of
foreign families-- 5%.
They were Italians.
But the percentage
of Negro families-- 90%.
And as we make our way
down the description sheet,
we see "This concentration
of Negroes in Evanston
is quite a serious problem
for the town,
as they seem to be
growing steadily
and encroaching into
adjoining neighborhoods."
These maps are how
the federal government
institutionalized segregation,
and they used race
to determine the value of all
of these neighborhoods.
So I want to understand
how all of these red lines
are impacting people's
lives today.
H.O.L.C. was passed in 1933,
and before that time,
places where H.O.L.C.
made those red-lining maps
and places that didn't
have those maps
were about the same level
of segregation.
And the measurement
that we use is a fairly common
measurement of segregation
called Black Isolation.
Then by 1950, 1960,
we see that cities
that were where
the redlining maps were created,
there's this huge jump here.
This one sort of moment,
they were collecting the data
and published the data
and it vastly impacted
millions of American lives
from that point on.
Yeah. This gap emerges
especially as the Federal
Housing Administration
and the G.I. Bill
kick in after H.O.L.C.,
and then we're layering on
schools, highways, et cetera.
Suburbanization.
And then all that
gets locked in place.
So I would say that
the gap that we see today
is a result of
structural racism,
which includes the wealth gap,
it includes
this history of exclusion.
It includes the intentional
segregating of neighborhoods.
What impact did this have
on our economy
and the ability for people
to participate in it?
Housing segregation
has all these other
layers on top of it,
including education and
employment opportunities.
So the isolation
of people of color,
in this case specifically
African-Americans,
has dramatically limited the
ability of African-Americans
to kind of achieve what
we generally consider to be
kind of middle class status--
home ownership,
wealth stability,
the ability
to pass on resources
to the next generation.
Any other interesting
takeaways from this?
It didn't have to be this way.
So we just learned about how
the government has historically
segregated neighborhoods
across America,
but I wanted to understand
how these problems
are affecting people today.
I'm getting ready to meet up
with two former testers
from the Fair Housing
Justice Center.
So, tell me exactly
what a tester is.
What did you all do
in that capacity?
It's a way of finding out what
landlords or real estate agents
are saying to people when they
think no one else is listening.
If you're a real person
going out looking for a home
to rent or to buy,
you provide your information
and you're given
certain information
about what's available
in what neighborhoods
at what price levels.
You have no way if knowing
if someone of a different
race or ethnicity
or any of the protected
characteristics is being told
the same thing as you.
What are the ways that we're
seeing housing discrimination
play out right now?
Any time I hear somebody say,
"Oh, white supremacy,
white privilege is just a myth
in this country," I say,
"Come do my job for half
an hour and you'll see the way
the doors get opened for me."
I actually had this
very nice woman in Brooklyn
showing me an apartment.
We're always instructed
to convey disinterest.
She said,
"Tell you what I'm gonna do.
Let me write down the number
for the entry code
for the lobby door.
If I'm not here,
you just let yourselves in.
Go up to the fourth floor.
Show her around the apartment
because I'd really love
to see you guys in here."
Most of my experiences
are not like Craig's at all.
I don't want to paint
the picture that every time
I'm sent out to test
I'm discriminated against,
but I have been
involved in cases
where very clear
discrimination happened.
At times,
I am shown the apartment,
but I'm quoted a higher rent.
$300 over my white counterpart.
At times, not shown
amenities in the building.
Not encouraged to apply
where my white counterpart
was encouraged to apply.
Lisa, what is--
what do some of those
experiences that you've had,
what do they tell you
about what regular folks
might be going through?
When you're a tester, we're--
as an African-American,
I'm representing all
the African-Americans that went
and inquired at that building
and were lied to,
so I represent so many
other people of color
who are experiencing this
while just looking for housing,
and housing is a basic need.
So, when my dad
sold our house in D.C.,
we had to get it
appraised twice.
And the first time it was
appraised, the value was set
at about $800,000.
But my dad knew that
our neighbors on the same block
were selling their houses
for much more that that.
So we spoke to a realtor
who told him
to take all of
the family photos off the walls,
leave them bare,
and get it appraised
a second time.
And that second appraisal,
the value was set
at about $1.2 million.
And at the time,
I didn't think that was
motivated by race,
but now after talking
to these testers,
I'm starting
to think that race
maybe played a role
in the home's valuation.
- Toby?
- Yeah.
- Hey, man, I'm Lee.
- Good to meet you.
Tell a little bit
about what you guys do
at Open New York.
So we are a pro-housing group.
We advocate for more housing
and more affordable housing
all across New York.
We are on 11th Street
between Fifth and Sixth Avenue
in Brooklyn Park Slope.
And we're looking at a building
that couldn't be built today
- as of right now in Brooklyn.
- Why is that?
So, the zoning rules
prohibit it.
So, in 2003,
this area was downzoned.
Lee: Why would people want
to downzone this neighborhood?
If you owned here,
restricting supply
is in your interest
because it makes your
own property more valuable.
And that's been the story
here for the last 40,
going on 50 years.
Lee: New York City
famously rezoned nearly
200,000 properties
between 2003 and 2007 under
the Bloomberg administration.
But a lot of this rezoning
was actually downzoning.
Here in Park Slope, some areas
were downzoned to preserve
the historic brownstones,
while other areas were rezoned
to increase housing density.
How does this impact
segregation at a racial level,
at an economic level?
It's brutal, right?
By privileging incumbents,
and by incumbents
I mean largely home owners,
you're entrenching all
of your existing segregation.
And let's be honest,
America is way
too segregated today.
As so by downzoning,
if this were
a white neighborhood,
you're making it much harder
for it to become
a more diverse area.
Absolutely.
You are actively
working against it.
( phone ringing )
Fabiola, what's up?
How are you?
Hey, Lee, I'm good.
I'm good.
I just got in touch with
this mother in Philadelphia
whose children are struggling
with lead poisoning.
And I want to go talk to her
because I feel like this story
might really embody
the very real consequences
of housing segregation.
But I'm still looking
for someone to talk to
about home ownership
and the racial wealth gap,
and I thought you might
have some ideas.
Someone that
I've actually talked to before
on this is Andre Perry.
He's a Fellow at the Brookings
Institute, actually,
- so he's based here in D.C.
- That's perfect.
Do you have time to talk
to him while I'm in Philly?
Fabiola: Yeah. I'll see
if I can get in touch with him.
- Lee: Amazing.
- Why is home ownership
important in terms
of economic mobility?
Well, when you own a home,
you're more likely
to be economically
and socially mobile.
But home ownership also
precludes you from moving
every time there's
an economic shock.
Home ownership predicts
for better health,
particularly
during a pandemic.
I can't think of another asset
that is so influential
on a person's life chances
than housing.
What have you found
about the differences
in property value
between predominately
black neighborhoods
and predominately
white neighborhoods?
What does that chart tell us?
Andre:
Homes in neighborhoods
where the share
of the black population
is less than a percent
on average are priced
about $340,000.
And as the percent
of black people
in a neighborhood increases,
you see
the home prices decrease.
So much so that when
the share of the black
population is 50% or higher,
the home prices on average
are about half as much
as their white neighborhoods.
So you're saying
it's as simple as
the more black people
in a neighborhood,
- the less the houses are worth?
- That's exactly right.
A lot of people will look
at that prior chart and say,
"That's because of education.
That's because of crime."
We control for education,
crime, walkability,
all those fancy Zillow metrics.
And what we found is homes
in black neighborhoods
are underpriced about 23%,
about $48,000 per home.
Cumulatively,
that's about $156 billion
in lost equity.
And how does racial segregation
factor into housing valuation?
Well, you know, segregation
has a long-standing impact
on a number of things.
Cities are becoming more
concentrated with poor folk,
and that is reducing
those areas' abilities
to pay for services
like education,
policing, infrastructure.
So when you concentrate
poverty in areas,
not only are you
putting a target on those
communities' back
in terms of harmful policies,
but you have less resources
in a neighborhood.
We have got to address this
because if folks
can't achieve
the American dream
through housing,
then they're not going to
achieve the American dream
in any other part
of their life.
So, I'm on my way
to Philadelphia,
a city where
nearly 8% of the children
under the age of seven
are struggling
with lead poisoning.
Lead is a heavy metal,
and when it gets
into your blood,
it can cause anything
from a reduced IQ to ADHD,
and some research has actually
linked it to school failures
and even criminality.
And while lead paint
has been illegal since 1978,
a number of the homes
here in Philadelphia were built
well before then.
So I'm getting ready
to meet up with a family
whose lives have been reshaped
by their zip code.
- Hey.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm good. I'm Lee.
Nice to meet you.
- I'm Angel.
So where are we right now?
Oh, man, we're in the area
of Olney in Philadelphia.
Okay. And you used to
live out here?
- Yes, I did.
- So, your kids got sick
living in this house?
- Angel: Yes, they did.
- What happened?
Angel: I took them
to the doctor one day
just for a random checkup,
and I come to find out
my daughter
had a nine lead level,
and my son,
at the time he was two,
he had an 18 lead level.
Lee: Jesus.
What happened
after you found out that your
children had lead poisoning?
- I contacted--
- Did you call the landlord or--
Yes, I contacted
the landlord.
The city were actually
called by the doctors.
They had to do gun tests.
My children's room,
which was the middle room,
they had the highest lead levels
in the whole house.
How were you dealing with this?
You know, you're working.
You're a working mom.
- You have three children.
- It's hard. It's hard.
It's extremely hard.
Who wants to have
their children
get lead poisoning?
But when you are
a single parent,
you have three children,
you're doing
everything by yourself,
how can you make enough money
to just up and leave?
What kind of a message
did that send you about,
you know, where you live?
You know, if you
were living center city,
it just wouldn't happen.
The suburbs,
it would not happen.
So when you made the decision
to get your kids out of here--
Yes, I did.
I actually moved to a hotel.
- For how long?
- For about a month,
a month and a half.
- Where are you living now?
- In Reading.
- Reading? Where is that?
- Yes. About an hour and ten
minutes away from here.
- Can you show me where?
- Yeah.
- Lee: Okay, so this is
your new house in Reading?
- Angel: Yes.
- So tell me about this place.
- Well, when I first got here,
it looked immaculate.
- Right.
- Three days after,
my walls started
to have a little crumbling
where I saw water.
- Can you show me?
Can we take a look?
- Yes. Yes.
Up here, there's mold
all throughout the ceiling.
This is where the water
leaks at on the floor.
And here, this is more
water damage.
This right here was seeping
water the other day.
- Jeez.
- There's mold down here
just coming out the wall.
So I went from one bad situation
to a worse situation.
I'm literally on unemployment
because I was
laid off at my job.
I have nowhere to go.
When people say things like,
you know,
America's the land
of opportunity.
You just gotta work hard.
You just gotta pull yourself--
That's a lie.
Because I moved from
the last place to come here.
So what's next?
Okay, so I know
that I grew up privileged.
I know that I was
incredibly fortunate to have
attended great schools,
to know from a young age
that I could afford
to pay for college
and to just have
fresh air to breathe
and clean water to drink.
What I didn't know
growing up
was that this was
an incredibly rare experience,
especially if you're someone
that looks like me.
I had no idea that
the full weight of history
was actively working against me
having that experience.
My parents beat the odds,
largely because
we always owned homes
in this family
going back generations,
and that had a direct impact
on my chances in life.
But the scarcity of stories
like mine isn't a problem
that any one of us can fix.
It is, however,
something that we don't have
to passively accept.
In trying to find out
whether or not your zip code
determines your future,
I did see some bright spots.
For decades, zoning laws
were used to restrict access.
But now in some cities,
they're being used
to encourage investment
and create
more diverse neighborhoods.
There are private firms
that are investing
in low income luxury housing
that's meant to convert
renters into homeowners.
And some landlords and members
of the real estate industry
have woken up to the role
that they've played
in perpetuating
housing segregation
and restricting
the upward mobility of our
neighbors for generations.
For every dollar the typical
white household has,
the typical black household
has about nine or ten cents.
And this is connected directly
to this legacy of redlining
and exclusion
from the opportunity
to build home equity.
So undoing that
is going to require as big
if not a bigger investment
than was made in the New Deal.
Let's excite the economy
in the same way
we're doing during COVID,
the same way we did after
the Great Depression,
but we just didn't do it
for black people.
So now's the time to really
correct those wrongs.
Ultimately, we can't reverse
the course of history
without those
who dug this hole
reaching in
and pulling us back out.
( indistinct chatter )
( chatter continues )
Woman: Hell, yeah.
Do y'all want to change
this background?
Woman 2: "I'm Lee,
and I'm gonna find out."
Lee: You want, "I'm Lee
and I'm gonna find out?
Or do you want,
"Does your neighborhood
determine your future?
I'm Lee Adams, and this is
'Glad You Asked' by Vox."